welcome back to New rockstars and
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 promises
the end of the Guardians as we know it
is very sad because I love all these
people but does that mean the end of the
Star-Lord mantle what if I told you that
Peter will no longer be Star Lord
anymore in the MCU and what if I told
you that the MCU will be getting its
first ever star Lady this is Rogue
Theory the show will re-pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love a show made possible by the
support of North VPN more on those
beautiful people in a minute but my name
is Mt and Greg work with me today is the
only Celestial child I know it's Jessica
Clemens what's going on what's going on
um hi it's now a trend that I will only
wear uh soap on it this is foreign
I keep trying I keep trying if anyone is
watching a silk body to keep uh this uh
no hair very uh warm it's very simple
very very cold
um and the queen of the ravagers of the
cosmos it is Whitney van luntingham
what's going on with me hi I'm good how
I don't have anything cool on my head
today
kind of even I decided to practice and
it doesn't look too uneven today so
that's my I like it that's my physical
attribute I'm saying with my
introduction I like it you got you got
you also have nice hair I love your hair
oh thank you thank you I appreciate it
and uh oh my goodness could it be the
even higher evolutionary it is Tommy
bechton what's going on Tommy great to
be here big hey head gang send me some
boy Bonnets and if my perks were any
nicer I'd shut down the internet that's
what I'm saying
you sure
[Music]
I want to be wavy let's go oh God you
always wavy baby all right here we go uh
our first topic for the day is I believe
that the next Star-Lord of the MCU will
not be uh Peter Quillen and when I'll be
a man it will be none other than Peter
Quill's lovely new baby sister mantis
um of the Guardians of the Galaxy and
here's why
um Peter's mom named Peter the Star-Lord
it's a very intimate title it seems but
I feel like there's a reason here I
think that she named him Star-Lord
because he's a child of a Celestial
being and like that's why
um he's the Star-Lord likes I believe
that ego The Living Planet is a star
being and since you know mantis is the
child of ego she is also
um like inherits the the via the cosmo
the cosmic power of the Stars which is
why she's able to do all that weird mind
[__] like all her powers are basically
based in ego's powers and I believe at
the end of Guardians 3 Peter Quill will
settle down to protect his new family on
his this new nowhere installation that
he has uh much like in the comics he he
was a ruler of a planet for a while in
the comics
um which is kind of weird that like
every time I see him like when I watch
my guardians of galaxy one I was like
this Peter quote would never be in
charge of him
he's super responsible he forgot that he
had a one-night stand in the back of his
ship before he went on like a very
dangerous Mission and almost very
dangerous like that guy can't almost
killed the planet I don't trust him I'm
sorry no like Guardians won Peter grew
up so much over the course you guys are
ridiculous what is he doing on nowhere
right now he's ruling it that's right
he's taken into his own yeah he's doing
great trust him
but I don't understand
[Laughter]
but I would trust like I would trust
Guardian three Chris Pratt over
Guardians with Chris Pratt any day he
learned he grew two of these people bro
and so I think by the end of this he's
going to get a new family he's like you
know what I'm over the death of my mom I
got all these people as my family so I'm
gonna stop running away from my being uh
being part of a family and mantis my
sister you're new here like ego kept you
on his Planet like on the edge of the
universe forever and you don't know
anything really you you just experienced
Christmas for the first time you need to
go experience the universe and protect
it as the new Star-Lord and so he hands
her the mask and so we're gonna have a
cool Star Lord with with uh antenna
which I really love the image of
um as mantis I love that that's like
really cool a gift that's a reward you
have to take over washing the entire
galaxy
good luck with that have a good time I'm
like please take this away from me
please take this away from me I think
that's a great Theory do you have it I
was like I didn't mean to cut you off
also I think but that's pretty much you
I think I think mentioned the Mantis
becoming the next Star-Lord and I've uh
stolen those words from your mouth uh no
I talked about it on the break room and
I say that it is yours I'm like mt has
come up with this theory that mantis
will be the next Star-Lord and I think
that's a great idea especially with all
the Avengers passing on the title
um not killing him necessarily but just
passing a title is also a form of just
like
leaving right like you know like not
everyone has to die yeah like they need
to be like basically suspended for the
MCU you can just like just be like all
right I'm leaving you know and this is a
going on record recorded because
everyone messages me and goes Jessica
why do you want to kill everyone in the
MCU and I'm like I don't want to kill
everybody
will sink
bottom of the sea floor and they will
all die in the battle world but damn I
just wanted to be set right here I
didn't say you had to kill Star-Lord I
said he could just pass on the gauntlet
so it's true it's true people can just
retire
yeah what do you guys think I like it
and I'll tell you why I like anytime uh
nepotism happens
[Laughter]
I think I think you know even if it's
found nepotism even if you didn't
realize you were related to someone for
a while I still think that you know
quill handing it's a different type of
Star-Lord right it's a different it's a
it's a different energy uh gone away is
this like over like golden retriever
energy star and and here to stay is this
empathetic gentle kind but also
vindictive when she wants to be get you
know I like it mantis is a wild card put
the put the helmet on give her the jet
pack and away we go baby I'm I'm all in
I don't know if we're voting right now
but I'm going rogus on this hey let's go
an early rogue's decision damn okay okay
what you think Whitney oh man I really
like this Theory I have one question
though so like yes so he's Star-Lord are
we do we think that that's Lord and Lady
Lord or do we think it's like the holy
Lord because then when mantis be star
lady or would she be star what's the
feminine version of Lord I mean is it
like goddess I don't know
Madonna yeah
see that's cool that's cooler I like it
because I'm also like why are they doing
Lords and Ladies and space that's weird
like they have like a royalty Castle
system like Buckingham Palace in space
okay
I like the idea that in space they
genuinely were like let's just take from
this weird planet uh the this one place
it's called the United Kingdom and let's
use them as a blueprint for how we
should do our cookies oh really yeah
let's just go away there's Lords and
Ladies and this is this is right they
chose the UK they chose the UK no
offensive people watching from the UK
you guys have a great monarchy
are you sure great monarchy
for
eign
but like no just thinking back to the
Guardians holiday special and how mantis
was kicking so much ass then like just
seeing her evolve from like this very
like timid like I don't want to like you
know talk to anybody or like or anybody
to like I will kick anybody's ass in
this room at any time like that to me
I'm like yo they're setting her up to be
yeah much more like the badass person
that she is in the comics I agree I
agree I I I agree with you I think I
think this makes a lot of sense I think
it's a great move I think it keeps an
actor who wants to probably stay in the
MCU in the MCU it allows another actor
who wants to spread their wings and fly
away uh to spread their wings and fly
away I'm all in empty I'm going rogus
I'm going wrong all right I can't follow
this okay this is also like the first
time I've never argued you on your idea
yeah
I think something's happening first you
had the earthquake earlier today and now
I think it's a great idea I think it's
sound I think also your best friends are
James Gunn he's telling you your secrets
uh so yeah that's awesome I think I
forgot about it we have sleepover she's
like all right this is yeah this is
Rogue Theory not Rogue secrets from your
sleepover but EMT don't you ever come to
this [__] party with that bro I wish
I was President y'all just roasting some
s'mores in a tent in the backyard
talking oh my God talking about the
things you love yeah
but it's the one that levitates and oh
no it gets away from you
I really remember I'm not gonna lie I
think that'd be fine I really freaking
hope that helmet comes back in season
two like it's just like up in the ass
came back let's just vote on this I
guess that's pretty much it what do you
think about this Theory um
oh my God unanimous
[Music]
freaking suck ass
you know what I think your theory is
gonna whip ass not suck ass okay Bob
next just has an amazing Theory because
she's an amazing woman with an amazing
brain but uh before that be sure to head
on over to direct salesmirch.com to
check out our latest merch options and
be sure to keep your eyes on our merch
store because very soon we'll be
dropping our Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum mini inspired merch I really
love these freaking shirts they're so
dope I love the art like you guys are
gonna love this and just in time for the
film to release support this Channel and
check out all of our awesome merch
options over at New roxasmerch.com and
we want to thank norvpn for sponsoring
this podcast have you ever gotten
extremely hyped to watch a new series or
film only to discover it's not available
for streaming in your country well
nordvpn has you covered with nordvpn you
can switch your virtual location on your
device with one click giving you the
ability to access streaming services
from over 60 countries at no extra cost
and this opens up a Quantum realm full
of entertaining content which you
wouldn't be able to access without
nordvpn with over
5400 servers 5400 servers in 60
countries nor VPN gives you access to
games and streaming platforms that are
currently not available in your region
and the best part is nordvpn will not
slow down your online experience not for
one second they've done the speed test
and nordvpn is the fastest VPN out there
and they even help you keep safe from
hackers malicious sites and pop-ups
while browsing the internet all with
just one click so grab your exclusive
nor VPN deal by going to nordvpn.com
Rogue Theory and you will get a huge
discount of your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus gift it's completely risk-free
with nord's 30-day money-back guarantee
well that's nordvpn.com Rogue Theory and
um since Tommy has a uh wonderful item
to show you guys uh he's gonna be taking
over this next spot hey you
yeah
I'm sorry spoiler alert hey hey that's
enough hey you you listener make 2023
the year you finally become the proud
owner of a sword where would you
purchase a sword you might ask
from battling Blades of course battling
blades designs and sells high quality
swords axes machetes and knives striving
to design and create products with the
highest quality Metals bone wood and
leather The Four Horsemen of Sword
building as I always say and it's more
than just the blades battling blades
also sells armor Shields and helmets to
really get into character looking for
something a little more personal
battling blades will take your custom
order to make the blade of your dreams
seriously check out their incredible
sight and see everything they have it
offer we've got their high carbon
Damascus steel Boston sword in the
office and it's awesome and oh you can
only wield it if you're a bastard okay
and I am a bastard
so if you want 20 off the best purchase
of your life you're battling blades
order go to battlingblades.com and enter
code Rogue at checkout that's
b-a-t-t-l-i-n-glige.com and
get 20 off your freaking sword man let's
go I mean guys we are talking to the
rogus audience out there and every Rogue
needs a sword all right
come on spring is coming Renaissance
Fairs are coming they are Awakening you
just need to get your photos done with
an actual sharp very very sharp blade
yeah
I almost cut myself with so many times
it's so fun to play with yes please if
you get this please wield it responsibly
please don't hurt anybody
knows how to wield a weapon as elegant
as the Bastard Sword so I have no
problem with it I use it to shave in the
morning yes and if you notice my face I
ain't talking about face shaving oh
my god Tommy the bravest among us all
Tommy's been circumcising himself every
three months
it just goes back so fast
that's my superpower at this point it's
more like an eight skin it's not a
foreskin
ready
let's go babe let's go Jessica
which leads us to our second topic for
today uh Take it Away Jessica thank you
so I will be looking this way because I
wrote a lot of notes for mine and I am
very tired
so if you find holes just let me know I
take I take notes very well uh criticism
uh okay so my topic is the nor Dimension
is within the quantum realm and Miss
Marvel actually draws her energy from
Kang directly oh so let me get into this
because if you forgot what the nor
Dimension is it's in Miss Marvel and
I'll get into it because it's we're the
home of the clandestines is but anyways
so my first round of evidence the
similarity between Kang and Shang Chi
and Miss Marvel's Bengals uh screen
Crush already has come up with like a
really great theory about how these are
quantum bands that drive energy from the
Quantum Zone and I still agree with this
I also agree that the the man's all
Illuminating this bluish purple tone are
all directly connected to Kang's rings
in the quantum realm that give off the
same Hue so these Quantum Vans could
have been made with the energy from the
quantum Zone by Kang eventually because
we know Kang is a time traveler and has
lived in different different times so
it's like how old and how long has he
been in the quantum room we don't know
so he could have been just making bands
Across the Universe in different
dimensions for a very long time evidence
number two is for Miss Marvel so I think
Miss Marvel's powers are yes within her
but I think the bracelets help draw more
power from the Nord Dimension and if the
quantum realm in the comics is a form of
the quantum Zone I think that Band
Theory still holds up and the nor
Dimension would possibly live inside the
quantum Zone inside the quantum realm I
know this is ridiculous and but I let me
keep going I promise Bruno said in Miss
Marvel that it helps the clandestines
get back home that it would make a
really big boom which I already think is
giving way to the Escape that's gonna
happen been in quantumania in
quantumania we know people are going to
leave but we don't know how people are
going to leave if they have Kang's
Powers because in Miss Marvel they were
like if you use your bands to get these
clandestines out of the nor Dimension
it'll cause a huge boom a huge Ruckus
and I think that's what's going to
happen when Kang exits the quantum realm
in quantumania which is going to make a
ripple effect not incursions per se but
something else super big and that's
going to be the post-credits scene we
also know that there's different
factions in the quantum realm so I think
one of those factions are the
clandestines and the nor Dimension and
the veil is the way to get into it you
have to be a clandestine or you have to
have been particles you need those Kang
bracelets or you need those pin
particles I also think Miss Marvel has
the ability to time travel due to her
bracelets being directly connected to
Kane evidence number three this is the
last of it I promise the sun Chi part
the history of the 10 rings in the
comics they belong to those like Dragon
people the McCall the empty how do you
pronounce these the McCulkin I say
McClure
the ten Rings belong to the Macaulay
culkins and the Mandarin found that axon
car ship that held the 10 Rings now old
Comics can be retconned and also found
untrue so I think this ship was not the
mcculkens I think this was Kang ship and
those were Kang's rings in the ship and
he got banished to the quantum realm
leaving behind those 10 rings and that's
where the Mandarin found them and that
signal that the Rings are giving off are
to the quantum realm because Kang is
trying to get that signal out but no
one's getting it back in until Cassie
does it in quantumania so I think these
rings are all attached to the king but
more specifically I think the Nord
Dimension is in the quantum Zone which
is in the quantum realm and that's where
Miss Marvel gets her powers no way
[Music]
no that's so fun dude no I love this
Theory considering um just like the the
visuals that we got at Miss Marvel
especially during the the time when we
saw the veil crack open like seeing that
the like the crack imagery in Miss
Marvel but also seeing it in the the
newest Quantum media trailer uh there
seems to be some type of connection
there and I love the idea that Kang is
like the the one that owned all this
technology he's like oops all my
technology is just out there it's just
out there in the way that it's not
supposed to be used yeah I love this and
like I would love to see the
clandestines in
um live action in in like the Cinematic
Universe to give them more of like a
backstory because we didn't get much
from like what the clandestines even
were so if they showed up in quantumania
it would be amazing I would love that so
much yeah yes I hope they piece it
together this way I feel like the nor
Dimension was like a not a throwaway but
since it doesn't really exist this in
the comics they kind of just were like
yeah we're just gonna make them from a
random place they'll and so I was like I
wanted to be involved somehow in a
bigger picture so what if that bigger
picture is that they're within the
quantum realm and the only people I can
get in there are the clandestines The
Bangles that belong to Kang or pin
particles
um
Jessica I love this because that was one
part of Ms Marvel that left me a little
bit unfulfilled was just kind of a
better understanding of the clandestines
and the Nord Dimension I felt like like
you said because it was something they
were inventing for the show they they
kind of half measured it they were like
we'll introduce it but It ultimately is
not fully we don't fully understand it
yet but that vmc is smarter than that
they're not just gonna have like a giant
glaring a plot hole I don't think I
think it was probably something to get
paid off possibly in a movie like
Ant-Man quantumania Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania so Jessica I gotta say I
know we're not voting yet but I'm going
rogus
Tommy's always jumping he's going he was
always like you know what I'm voting now
or rogus I love it
um but yeah no I I like this a ton
especially considering that King suit
does shoot out a blue energy much like
uh kamala's Bangles do and like that if
that blue energy is very very
interesting to me but yeah like I and
also like his I think that the this gold
material that yeah a couple of those
Bangles are made out of it's also
probably the the same type of gold I
mean gold is gold but like
um in King's time cheer we saw we got a
new image
so like maybe like there's a similar
type of Technology at work with his
chair with uh connected to the mall's
Bengals so like I like this I can't wait
till we see uh King in quantumania and
he treats the rings that like shung Chi
and the Bangles that Ms Marvel have like
the paperweights of in Loki the the like
the infinity stone the Infinity Stones
yeah he's gonna just be like oh yeah
this is just jewelry that I made and I
can't find my other one
I just like the way they tie the outfit
together yeah
I must have left it in that weird
timeline where there was Dragon people
running around cat no nobody but no I
think I I don't know Jessica do you like
dragons
I don't want to talk about it okay
Imagine Dragons
he's setting me up for Tommy I do love
dragons oh okay cool
thank you
okay go ahead okay what do you think
Whitney oh man no I I really like this
idea I think it's very [__] cool uh
everyone else kind of said everything I
was thinking so yes thanks nice okay so
Rogue is from Whitney what'd you think
Tommy oh it's a rogus for me all the way
empty it's been a rogus from day one one
I'm smarter than to go against my queen
my moon and stars the love of my life
Jessica Clemens but two genuinely this
Theory makes perfect sense to me and I
can't wait to be rewarded with it being
correct yeah okay nice and I will give
this a rogus as well because like I love
the connections that he made he put a
lot of real like thought into this like
I like that you wrote these notes down
because I liked all these thoughts what
a feel-good example this has been this
was like this should be like an essay
also and it did
I wish I could have sent you guys all a
little snippet so you could follow along
I was like I'm talking so [__] much
oh sorry I'm cursing I'm talking so ref
and Mark oh my God this is a Christian
show this is a Christian show or no
cursing we get live streamed to churches
across yeah they play this at Hillsong
when Chris Pratt goes to Max
plan their intermission at Hillsong
um that's how Chris Pratt now knows that
I think he would be a bad leader oh yeah
and that really hurt he's like I'll show
her sorry dude I'll show her
I'll show everybody skull has ever seen
but it's now time for our real question
are you guys ready yeah okay so with the
Academy Award nominations coming out
this week we are excited to see black
panther workout in Forever pick up some
nominations now the Oscars don't always
award the movies that we love the most
so give me your rogus Oscar nomination
that you would like to have seen this
year yeah I got it uh my mine is gonna
be for uh best special effects
uh to go to top gun Maverick for the
offense on offense football scene uh
where they made all of those actor boys
look like they could throw footballs uh
with tight spirals because you know that
was done digitally I love it I love that
that's what you I know in the movie you
were like you were like that's they
didn't throw that football there's no
way absolutely it's been I mean there's
a long tradition of actors that can't
throw being playing athletes Tim Robbins
is kind of the gold standard Tim Robbins
in uh in uh balderum he's supposed to be
like a pitcher that can throw like a
hundred mile an hour fastball and when
you watch them throwing paper he doesn't
know what a baseball is yeah anyway
that's my vote uh I nominate uh best
visual effects top gun Maverick for the
uh Beach football scene which also
doesn't make sense that game doesn't
make sense Tom Cruise is a maniac I just
don't think Tom Cruise knows how
football is played and he's like this is
what I guess is on my TV anyway what are
you guys got
I don't know how football Works
um give me a second give me a second
give me a second okay I'm gonna vote for
uh the best I guess it would also be VFX
but the best
scene in which a large group of animals
jumps out of the back of a truck and RR
wins that baby
hell yeah baby I have to see this
freaking movie
you have to it's so good the animals
jumping out of the back of the truck
scene just trust me watch it you'll die
it's amazing okay like every time I see
RR I'm like is it red redemption
it does stand for something okay
really
um
okay I like that I'm gonna what you got
Jess I'm gonna uh there's gonna be a new
category called best frown face and it's
gonna nominate Florence Florence Pew
don't worry Darlene
don't worry
oh best Brown face who gets the award
Jess don't worry darling and the winner
goes to Florence Pew with the best
frowny yeah
the the sad face emoji face it's
literally the best
I can't do it
it just looks weird when I try I can't
do it
why do we even make that feels like a
sad face if no one ever makes the like
the actual
I don't know I guess like because it's
just the opposite of smile but it's like
no it's not like frowning it's more like
a straight line the happy face category
goes to smile the horror movie and
everybody wins everyone's dominated and
everybody everyone
okay you know what I'm gonna have to
give this to Jessica because like yeah
like that is Florence the proud face I
mean there needs to be like a category
for like stuff like that it's like all
right we're just I don't know face
this year best Expressions
[Laughter]
again
dubbed again
but yes that makes up Jess our Rogue
question winner for today uh but we are
all winners for we are all talking about
nerd stuff
um amongst all of our friends here on do
rock stars watching with us when we
thank you so much for joining us in this
episode of Rogue fearing we think are
also hooked to our guests Jessica
Clemens Winnie van luntingham and Tommy
Beck told you can support our Channel by
checking out all of our awesome merch
over at New roxasmerch.com you can
follow me at mastertonment follow me
rockstars on all social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
YouTube we'll see you guys next time we
love you guys so much stay safe and uh
be well goodbye bye eat cheese eat as
much cheese eat cheese but not if you're
lactose intolerant
it's okay yes oh God no that's bad
advice
[Music]